and book TVs live coverage from New York
City continues this is the inside of the
Javits Convention Center on the west
side of New York bookcon is happening
today this is a book festival open to
the public it follows on the heels of
book Expo America which is the
publishers annual convention and book TV
has been live all week here at Book Expo
America and today we're taking advantage
of the fact that we're still here and
we've invited author Chris Hedges on to
talk about his most recent book which
just came out this month
it's called wages of rebellion the moral
imperative of revolution mr. heads is
the first line in your book we live in a
revolutionary moment what do you mean I
mean have sustained the old system of
global capitalism lays a Fair capitalism
the idea that an elite accruing to
itself massive amounts of money will
somehow trickle down and make the middle
class in the working-class more
prosperous has been exposed as a lie the
institution's the political institutions
that perpetuate that ideology have lost
their support their efficacy Congress
has an approval rating of about 7 or 9
percent and we've entered what the
theorist Antonio Gramsci describes as an
interregnum a period where we have lost
faith in the ideas that buttress a
particular political and economic system
but we have yet to articulate or or find
a vision for what should replace it but
that the discontent is there even the
anger is there a sense of betrayal the
realization across the political
spectrum that in essence corporate power
no longer concerns itself with the
rights of grievances of citizen the
citizenry I think is is extremely
widespread so do you see collapse of the
current system ultimately yes the system
is not sustainable anytime a small cabal
of take and twists institutions of power
to serve their own ends then as you know
all the way back to Aristotle as
Aristotle wrote in politics then you end
up either with revolt or tyranny when
that comes what sets it off oftentimes
decane systems can sustain themselves
for a very long time the
austro-hungarian Empire was in rot from
probably from you know 1848 until the
end of World War two these systems can
go on a long time in essence what they
are are systems that don't respond
rationally to the rights and the needs
of citizens you know it doesn't matter
what the citizens want nobody wants
wholesale surveillance but we get it
anyway everybody is sick of the wars in
Iraq and Afghanistan but they never end
because they make a certain segment of
the economy that manufactures arms very
wealthy you know nobody wants these
trade these TPP or CAFTA agreements but
there Ram to do anyway and of course
they're held in secret even our
legislators are not allowed to speak
about them I sued Barack Obama in
federal court over section 1021 of the
National Defense Authorization Act which
allows the US military overturns over
150 years of domestic law and permitting
the military to seize American citizens
strip them of due process hold them in
military facilities indefinitely if they
are deemed by the state to be terrorists
we won in the federal the Southern
District Court of New York it was
appealed by the Obama administration and
unfortunately the temporary injunction
was lifted and it is it is still law but
we know from opinion polls on the NDAA
had a 97% disapproval rating these are
all symptoms of a state that doesn't
work on behalf of us and and that angst
I think really runs all the way across
the political spectrum now if the state
continues to ignore the legitimate
grievances and the suffering economic
suffering of the population despite
Appeals for a sensible reform than
inevitably it will trigger more radical
responses that will ultimately lead to a
confrontation between large segments of
the population in the state when it
comes what triggers it oftentimes these
things are triggered by a crisis the
case of Yugoslavia which I covered as a
foreign correspondent it was
hyperinflation but an economic meltdown
with climate change we are seeing of
course severe droughts in places like
California another act of catastrophic
domestic terrorism but anything that
kind of the system can't sustain a shock
and it triggers a reaction I mean I
would talk about black lives matter with
all of these people walking through the
streets of cities like Baltimore or
Ferguson we live in a country where
almost every 28 hours an African
American man or woman is shot dead
lethal force
they're usually unarmed we have videos
of our police actually murdering unarmed
civilians and yet despite the outcry it
continues and we have in the last month
seen a spate of shootings a police
officers one in New York two in
Mississippi just the other day - and I'm
hoping that these are just incidental
you know and but if that becomes a
pattern I mean that certainly would
replicate disintegrating societies that
I covered people reach such a level of
rage that they finally lash out but but
that's where we're headed the state is
is has turned attack on people like you
and me so how effective are some of
these rebellions right lives matter
occupy wallstreet ed Snowden right well
they're effective in this sense they
expose the lie that the state uses or
the myth the state uses to explain
itself to the public you know the idea
that we have a right to privacy and we
know from the Snowden revelations we are
the most photographed monitored watch
eavesdropped population in human history
and I covered the collapse of the Stasi
state in East Germany you can't use the
word Liberty when you are watched 24
hours a day by your government that is
the relationship of a master and a slave
and you never want to give any
government that kind of power because
when they accrue to themselves that kind
of power coupled with militarized police
coupled with a legal system that
essentially renders those the state
targets defenseless if they feel
threatened they will they will use all
the tools at their disposal to protect
themselves so
I say in the book I begin the book by
you know talking about past revolutions
and you know revolutions come in waves
often so you see what's happening in
Greece affecting what happens in Spain
affecting what happens in Ireland and
here in other parts revolutions
interestingly enough are fundamentally
nonviolent all of the great theorists of
revolution I quote crane Brinton and
here in Davies and others say that no
revolution I think this is correct is
successful until significant segments of
the internal security apparatus defect
or are no longer willing to protect a
discredited power elite so despite there
was certainly violence in the Russian
Revolution especially anarchist violent
assassinations of alexander ii etc but
what broke the back of the Czarist
regime was the Petrograd bread riots in
1917 they send the Cossacks who were
kind of the Tsar's enforcers they
refused to fire on the crowd they
fraternize with a crowd the Tsar is
rushed back from the front and he has to
abdicate in the railway citing a new
character now I watched the same thing
in East Germany and this certainly that
was them probably up until our state the
most sophisticated security and
surveillance apparatus
I mean dwarfing even Stalin's Soviet
Union so erich honecker the communist
dictator is upset about the street
demonstrations in leipzig where 70,000
people are marching through the streets
protesting the communist regime and he
sends down a lead paratroop division to
fire on the crowd they get there they
refuse to fire on the crowd
Honaker loses power within a week the
same thing with a shot soon as the
Mushaf flees the country and then the
armed forces in 1979 are no longer
willing to protect the shah and home a
Neama clerics are able to take over
that's how revolutions work and it goes
back to a 1978 essay by václav havel the
power of the powerless Havel of course
leading the Velvet Revolution and I also
covered the Velvet Revolution I was in
the Magic Lantern theatre every night
but hobble and Klaus didn't spare and
all these people inherited the
government but it's that that stating of
that becomes more and more obvious to
the wider society and obvious finally to
those who are within the organs of power
and they no longer are willing to
protect a discredited elite and I have
been involved with groups like occupy
but I've been a fierce opponent of like
black bloc anarchists who taunt the
police and we'll do property damage
because I believe that our greatest
strength is as Kabul said this living in
truth stating the truth and because once
revolutions become violent then it
empowers those who have not only a
capacity for violence or penchant for
violence but an access to weapons and
who prefer to speak in the language of
violence and they speak in the language
of violence not only to their opponents
but to each other and that's how Lenin
you know ends up crushing the anarchists
of the Soviets the Mensheviks through
violence and that having been a foreign
correspondent in societies such as the
war in Yugoslavia or I covered the war
in El Salvador for five years I
desperately don't want us to go there
and I believe that if a large large
enough segment of the population
probably three to five percent we're not
talking about you know are willing to
put their bodies in the street and
sustain way as we saw in Eastern Europe
we can begin to affect hopefully
nonviolent change because at this point
I think it's fair to say we're not going
to or at least in my analysis going to
affect change through the traditional
reformist mechanisms because they've
been eviscerated by corporate power
we've undergone a corporate coup d'etat
in slow motion and and I think it's over
how many years did you spend at the New
York Times 15 you've written about 10
books so so far 12 yeah maybe 14 ivory
up to 14 now this is the most recent
wages of rebellion the moral imperative
of revolt numbers are up on the screen
if you want to talk with Chris Hedges
Chhotu 7 for 8 8200 if you live in the
East in central time zones seven four
eight eight two zero one for those of
you out west and let's get into the
calls with beginning of a gym in
Massillon Ohio Jim you're on with author
Chris Hedges well the background noise
there is is tremendous I hope you can
hear me okay Peters Flynn you are the
best at what you do mr. hedges
I'm a retired schoolteacher I've got two
of your books on my Kindle right now the
world as it is and which is a billion
you put your finger on virtually every
black hole in our public structures you
have the ability wonderful ability that
like the only other person I've ever
seen quite like and I hope you'll take
this as a compliment was Christopher
Hitchens who's able to talk
extemporaneously on virtually any
subject for about an hour so I think
that that's terrific that you that you
know your topics so you you make the
following statement which which I
believe you also mentioned with Peter
democracy will eventually be replaced
with a robust national police state and
of course you know this builds to a lot
of the things we've been watching but I
want to put out a note of optimism here
I think the numbers are with us right
now I think I think there is a tilt
beginning to happen we may be as an
inflection point where and maybe the
police and the military are going to be
more
falling in line with the people as you
stated in one of your talks when someone
put the handcuffs on you they were
saying you know keep it up so if you
want to speak to the fact that maybe the
number there the tipping point or all
right Jim thank you very much for the
nice words and for your call
that's why non-violence is so important
you know we have to appeal to the
conscience of those within the power
structures and if we view the power
structure as a kind of monolithic enemy
as a force where people of good
conscience don't reside then I think
we're finished and you're right I was
arrested in front of the White House and
some of the police who are arresting us
this was the protest I was with veterans
for peace of protesting the wars in Iraq
and Afghanistan when they cuffed us it
turns out they'd been in the National
Guard and they hated the wars as much as
we did and as I was cuffed they said you
know keep protesting these wars and the
state of course recognizes that and
worries about that and I think part of
the reason they passed the NDAA which
permits the military to carry out
domestic policing in essence
extraordinary rendition on the streets
of American city is that because I think
they finally don't trust the police in a
moment of crisis to protect them Chris
Hedges I want to go to Jim's inflection
or tipping point
in some ways Rand Paul could have
written right parts of your board is
that it correct yes statement it is and
we can agree with that yeah I mean I'm
not a libertarian because I feel that
that the the only effective mechanism we
as citizens have to for corporate power
is government and that by making
government more anemic we make corporate
power more global or more omnipotent I
mean who is going to make sure that BP
doesn't go back and I mean the Gulf is
largely a dead zone but I mean who's
going to make sure that these things
don't happen you need a mechanism a
superstructure so I would disagree with
them on that but on the issue of
Imperial War and on the issue of
security and surveillance the
libertarians are really good and they
recognize the danger of both and so we
are in convergence and I know Ron Paul
will occasionally put articles that I
write up on his website usually on these
issues and of course I spent 20 years on
the outer reaches of empire I understand
the mechanisms of empire in a way that
Americans have probably haven't been
there do not and in fact the Senate will
be in on Sunday right debating the
surveillance and Patriot Act and USA
Freedom Act as it's called from the
house right they'll be coming in
on Sunday afternoon Larry's in Centralia
Washington hi Larry
in order to speak with mr. hedges saw
you at our bookstore in Portland Oregon
sometime bad but I'm wondering I the
Philippines when Marcos was thrown out
the army turned against him too because
I think he was gonna head I'm around the
people but my question is do you think
that the Iraq war was Dick Cheney shall
be king Halliburton were so and who's
now in Dubai after the billions of
dollars they made right the Iraq war and
I was a vocal opponent of the call to
invade Iraq I had been the Middle East
bureau chief for the New York Times I
spent seven years in the Middle East I
speak Arabic I recognize like most
Arabists and I would say the Erebus
within the intelligence community within
the Pentagon within the State Department
that the whole reason reasoning behind
invading Iraq was based on a non reality
based belief system the idea that we
would create it as liberators the idea
that the oil revenues would pay for the
reconstruction the idea that democracy
would be implanted in Baghdad and
emanate outwards across the Middle East
for a non reality based belief system I
I think that many of these ideologue
like Cheney Wolfowitz Perl Elliott
Abrams etc I think they believe their
own rhetoric they have no experience in
the Middle East at all or culturally
historically linguistically illiterate I
think they also believe that what's good
for us business or us corporations
although corporations are now global
what's good for corporations is good for
America I'm sorry there was a
convergence but fundamentally it was
based on frightening a frightening
misunderstanding of of the region and in
particular of the country and what we
what invading would do and you know they
always would say who's worse than Saddam
Hussein well you know Isis is worse than
Saddam Hussein and we created Isis in
much the same way we
Alpina firm wages of rebellion Chris
Hedges rights and revolutions when they
begin are invisible at least to the
wider society and start with the slow
discrediting and dismantling of an old
ideology and an old language used to
interpret reality and justify power you
also write that Keystone pipeline is
part of the final phase of extreme
exploitation could you explain that yes
and we'll go back to Karl Marx I'm not a
Marxist but I think Marx's analysis of
the inner workings of capitalism and
where it's going is correct and and
important in terms of reading and and
Marx argued that unfettered or
unregulated capitalism at the end became
a revolutionary force there were no
there's no internal impediments
obviously to accruing or gathering more
profit and once the external elements
are removed it then is free to exploit
everything human labour and the
ecosystem until exhaustion or collapse
and that's why the environmental crisis
is intimately twinned with the economic
crisis so 40% of the summer Arctic sea
ice melts shale oil races up to drop
half billion dollar drill bits into the
Arctic sea to profit off the death
throes of the planet the tar sands is
like letting a mattress because of
course it's even dirtier form of energy
and there's no impediment there's no
rational discourse about preserving our
future for our children and for
succeeding generations it's all about
you know profiting you know in the most
destructive way we can as fast as we can
and this is probably very good it is
very good for you know the bottom line
for large fossil fuel corporations but
it's very bad for the human race and and
that is essentially what's happened when
civil society is disintegrated the
common good is no longer a factor it's
not part of the equation Karl Polanyi
and the great transformation where he
writes about the nature of unfettered
Capital is actually he's always an
economist he uses the word sacred he
said when nothing has an intrinsic value
in the society when everything has a
monetary value then you have built
within it a self a nihilistic quality
which Marx also got and that's kind of
where we are we need to rapidly step
back from this kind of mentality I mean
the whole idea that the dictates of the
market place should govern every aspect
of human behavior is insane
no other society has tried it it's not
working out very well for us but I is a
father of four and terrified for what's
coming next and we have to build systems
essentially governmental systems that
are not wholly owned subsidiaries of
corporate power but become stewards of
our nation so that my children your
children and succeeding generations will
be able to inherit and live a life of
quality and and health and these
corporations that's not part of their
DNA that's not what they think bills at
Washington DC bill go ahead you know
thank you very much
brief preface brief question I'm 74
years old almost retired Army
psychiatrist and I subscribed a fringe
group of understanding group process
which in America goes under the term
Tavistock ta vis T Ock my question
what's happened to the concept of
government of by and for the people and
behind that if I firmly believe that the
entire group that constitutes our
citizenry is should feel responsible for
the entire action of our group and that
would even apply good or bad it could be
you know World War two the extremes on
either side are good examples but what
happens if you could get the lower 50%
to stop feeling like victims and start
feeling like contributors to what we
have using basically one of our pure
axiomatic statements government of by
and for the people that's what's on my
mind well I mean the consent of the
governed is how to become a fool joke I
think we see over and over and we spoke
a little earlier in the program about
all sorts of programs including the
bailouts constituent calls against the
bailout were one hundred to one across
the political spectrum and yet these
banks were bailed out anyway because
that's what the big ten Citibank and
Wells Fargo and Goldman Sachs these
other firms wanted and got and I think
that yes the consent of the governed
government of By and For the People
means exactly that a government is a
superstructure that is designed to
create a quality of life for its
citizens and I would argue in a
democracy watch out for the most
vulnerable children the elderly the sick
mentally ill who we've tossed out on
heating grates surplus labor as
manufacturing this moved overseas you go
into poor communities of color and these
people have no work no opportunity which
is why of course we have the largest
prison system in the industrialized
world 25% of the world's prison
population because black and brown
bodies can't create money for
corporations if they're out on the
street and there's no jobs but they can
generate forty or fifty thousand dollars
a year if they're locked in a cage
that's why a lot of these people we're
talking about you know huge numbers of
people who never committed a violent
crime that's why they're locked in cages
so I think on every single level the
primacy of corporate profit and
corporate power has trumped what is
fundamental to our democracy we need to
recover we need to recover our country
Jennifer's in Ruidoso Downs New Mexico
and you are on with Chris Hedges on book
TV Jennifer hi mr. hedges it's great to
speak with you I'm a great fan I have
one question
oil I have two but once really pressing
in my mind I'm glad you mentioned and a
double a and I thank you for suing the
president on behalf of the American
people we have operation Jade helm
upcoming and ten states to last two
months it's purported to be a military
action quote training two months ongoing
and they're using a lot of Special
Forces and I assume and it's hard for me
not to think that that will somehow fall
under the provisions of the nd double-a
are they coming to kill us are they
coming to put us in prisons and my next
point would be my next question to you
is have you found as I have found that
based on this as much surveillance that
we're subjected to and in all ways of
communications it's very difficult for
us to organize and to move forward as a
movement of the people against these
powers that be well let's talk about the
NDAA and judge Catherine reforest in the
Southern District of Port of New York
who imposed a temporary injunction
declaring the law unconstitutional my
former employer the New York Times
covered the trial and wrote a very good
editorial supporting the judge's
decision in that they now have the power
and we went to the Democratic leadership
by the way the lawyers brew saffron and
Carl Mayer and myself and said that we
would be willing to drop the lawsuit if
they would just write into the
provisions that this did not apply to
u.s. citizens which they would not do
because of course it does apply to u.s.
citizens and in judge forests opinion
she raises the internment of 110,000
japanese-americans during World War two
and
that this provision permits the
government to criminalize in her words
an entire group of people and and hold
them in essence in internment camps or
in military facilities where they can
sit without ever seeing a lawyer so
what's happening now we're not in a
state of crisis I don't think the state
needs to employ that kind of those kind
of draconian forms of control but should
the society disintegrate should there be
the kind of unrest that we see in some
European countries by Greece for
instance that they certainly will bring
in the military if they feel that they
need the military in order to retain
power and they will use these legal
mechanisms which they have created for
themselves against us I don't we're not
in a moment of crisis
right now we're in a moment of relative
stability so I think while yes you know
they put tanks on the streets of
Ferguson Missouri against unarmed
protesters while you see glimpses of the
capacity of the military state I think
we'd have to be in a kind of freefall
for us to begin to see this employed on
a very large scale wages of rebellion is
Chris Hedges newest book and Carl's in
Midvale Utah Carl's or what happened
Thank You mr. hedges for your insights
don't know if you're surprised to be
allied with Rand Paul as has been
mentioned and even Glenn back in your
stance on nonviolent protest
I was curious to know if your book has
any insight on things that people can do
to be persuasive with the government in
a non-violent way we seem to be in a
trend that's violence right now other
steps we can take to to be effective in
protesting in a non-violent way and and
not become criminalized
Thank You Karl well the problem is that
even nonviolent protest brings with it
the you know the use of a legal system
that has criminalized dissent so for
instance you've seen large numbers of
people who are very closely involved
with the Occupy movement charged with
felonies they're often allowed to plea
out but because they're on probation
they have to be very careful about doing
any kind of activism you know we have
seen the rise of omnipotent policing
only 94 percent of people in this
country go to trial most gets stacked
with plea charges many of which they
didn't commit and then they bargain
their way out so there's a there's a
legal system and a physical mechanism
that is used to criminalize and will be
used to criminalized even nonviolent
dissent and so for me I think it would
be foolish to believe that if we were
able to bring those numbers into the
street if we were able to carry out
sustained acts of mass civil
disobedience just because we were
nonviolent we would free ourselves from
the draconian forms of the state in some
ways the state fears those mass
movements far more than it does anarchic
violence because that kind of violence
frightens the mainstream and it gives
the state a license to use violence in
return and Linda is in Riverton New
Jersey Linda you're on book TV Thank You
hello Kristin thank you very much for
all the work that you do I'm very
thankful for the truth that you are able
to get out there I know recently you
became an ordained minister I saw the
event online and I was just wondering
personally how you deal with the
realization of all these things that are
going around all around us and just sort
of getting up in the morning and and
spiritually how you can you speak to
that on a on a personal and spiritual
life
and I would there's a lot of
spirituality and weight as a civilian as
well
well I come out of a faith tradition my
father was a minister I graduated from
Harvard Divinity School and I teach in a
prison in New Jersey and how for many
years and was ordained to an essence
continue that prison ministry because I
think finally it is an issue of faith
and I say this to people of who have
religious Creed's or have no creeds it
is the belief that the good draws to it
the good or at least the good insofar as
we can determine it and then we have to
let it go faith is the belief that it
goes somewhere the Buddhists call it
karma an act of faith standing up in a
sense that moral imperative a revolt
which for me as an act of faith is
finally not defined for what we can
achieve empirically things may be worse
by the end of our lives but more
importantly for who it allows us to
become as individuals and I think that
we're never going to confront these
terrifying forces that stand before us
whether it's the fossil fuel industry
the security and surveillance state
unless we remain rooted in some kind of
a spiritual tradition that sets us
outside of ourselves that is not tied to
the emotional highs and lows that define
American culture that that that allow us
to find validation in the act of
resistance itself and not get too caught
up in whether it's effective or not I
mean of course I hope we are effective
but even if we're not I don't think that
that should any way diminish the
importance of revolt Reinhold Niebuhr
the great theologian calls its sublime
madness and he said that in moments of
extremity liberalism is a spent an
ineffectual force it is that capacity
which you know he relates to the quality
religious mystics have which becomes
necessary in moments of extremity and I
would agree a Baldwin James Baldwin the
great writer and he writes his essay on
the
about how artists and rebels share
common characteristics said that they're
not they don't so much strive towards a
vision as as as much as they are
possessed by it and I think that's right
and I spend a lot of time in the book
talking about those issues because I
think I think they're fundamental if
we're gonna rise up and do what we have
to do and Cindy in Evansville Indiana we
have 30 seconds left
hi Chris I just want to tell you that
you're doing a very good job I just I
just appreciate it my husband bought all
your books so thank you I appreciate it
I I would just close by saying you know
I don't fight fascists because I'm going
to win
I fight fascists because they're
fascists and that when we see what
Hannah Aaron and or Manuel call would
call a radical evil forces that are
seeking to extinguish the systems of
life that are vital for the future of
our children there is a moral imperative
upon all of us to rise up on their
behalf and wages of rebellion the moral
imperative of revolt is the book Chris
Hedges is the author thank you
our live coverage from New York
continues now all week we have been in
New York City we've been interviewing
different people and one of the people
we talked to was Adam Bella he is the
son of Saul Bellow the author and but
he's also an editor and publisher at
HarperCollins he has a imprint called
broadside here's a little bit of our
conversation with Adam better in this in
snitch there was no presence of
conservative books in mainstream
publishing there was only Regnery which
is a venerable publishing company but
really a sectarian outfit that is
outside and so it proudly so outside
stands outside the mainstream we at the
Free Press that is myself at her when
Glick as who was the publisher of the
Free Press and by my mentor in the
business were engaged in an effort to
break down barriers to conservative
ideas and expression and it was an
exciting and consequential thing to do
after sometime after ten years or so
when we had enough success that the
large publishing companies woke up and
realized that there was a contact of
mass market a sizeable market for
conservative books then
special imprints began to be created and
they're now for at this present count
dedicated conservative inference at the
mainstream houses
and that was Adam bellow we take that
interview this week in New York City and
you'll be able to see that entire
interview on Saturday June 6 beginning
at 7:30 p.m. our live coverage from New
York our our coverage from New York will
be shown that evening well all week long
as I've said we've been in New York City
and Book Expo America has been happening
which is the publishers convention and
one of the panels that we covered was
about diversity in literature and
diversity in the book world here's the
pen